yeah so a bit about myself
uh my name's andrew eland i've worked at
google for about
um 10 years something like that and
somewhat of a world tour i spent a lot
of that time in our
in sights in zurich and then in london
and then i moved here a couple of years
ago
most of that time i worked on google
maps and so i ran the teams that built
google maps and mobile phones
more than happy to talk about google
maps mobile phones later on still a
passion of mine
but now i run a team at google called
social impacts
and we are a team of about 70 engineers
uh and we try to build products um
that's uh positive not just for google
users but for the whole world that's our
spin if
if the rest of google is building
products to help people who use google
services we build products that help
people who
don't um so we build
uh a set of services that
helps non-profits use google so we give
away a lot of google services for free
to non-profits so we build the
infrastructure that does that
we have a team of about uh 20 to 25
people who work
on crisis response or google's efforts
in times of crisis
so specifically we will um
buzz your phone if we think your life is
in imminent danger
uh and say um there has been a magnitude
7 earthquake
uh there is a tsunami approaching in 30
minutes you should get to high ground
and go here um so we go
kind of we call it the emergency
broadcast system for the for the real
world
um not going to talk about much about
that today can some other time
um and the uh other products we work on
are for politics and elections so
everything we do
in terms of helping people to vote
and educating people our goal there is
to help improve voter turnout because we
believe better voter turnout leads to
better decisions
so that's our metric get more people
like to vote
and also we look at ways to the google
can use
its data for the public good by
sharing it with other institutions the
most visible of that is
flu trends so i'm going to concentrate
a little bit on those two later like
most people
and i'm sure you've never done this i
probably made this talk
a little last minute maybe yesterday
this morning after my um
title was in so i thought i gave it the
generic talk of advanced technology for
the common good
uh given it's about data i'm actually
going to title it lessons from the cold
face of attempting to use data to
improve the world with a small amount of
advanced technology thrown in the end
not much
i'll give you lots of warning when we
get to the advanced technology bit so
you don't miss it
because the reality is that uh
a lot of the work that we do the
advanced science is uh less important
than how
it integrates into the public and
technical ecosystem
that it works in uh so i'm going to talk
a little bit about our work particularly
with
open data since open data is
a great source of uh research
investigation for all the interesting
things i'm sure you work on
and then i'll talk a little bit about
how google can release its own data
through things like flu trends later on
um so i will talk a little about this
feature that we launched for the us
mid-terms so what we did is we
want people when they needed to register
to vote in advance
and we said you know if you need if you
want to vote in the upcoming elections
um do this so this was uh appeared in
google now
um so if you use that it uh gives you a
stream of
interesting information um and then we
notified people's phones when early
voting was
uh available as well as normal voting
later on who here knew that you could
early vote in elections here
yeah what's that 20 probably about that
yeah that's what i would have expected
that but it turns out
you can you don't have to vote on
polling day
you can vote before when there are less
queues and less trouble
so we in an effort to increase turnout
we
launched the card that notified people
in advance to say you should go and vote
now and we've been doing this actually
for a while this is just the most recent
incarnation of it but for um since
2008 in web search you could search in
google where do i vote and we
um tell you where to vote um so
uh let's think about what you need to do
um
uh to build this feature um you would
know if you think okay to build this
feature first of all we need to know
where all the polling places are and
where people are registered
to vote so we can say you need to go and
vote in this polling place
so you'd think oh well let's just go to
the government and say please give us a
list of all the polling places
so that's what we did and what happens
if you do that is you end up with
something like this
this is just one um example that this is
the data that we got
for dale kelty alabama you'll notice
that it is
a a fax that has been typed up not in
any kind of structured form
my particular favorite feature is this
thing at the top where they've just
scratched out the previous year put the
new one on
and uh and you can imagine doing this
at a precinct level or city level state
level all across the u.s
every place across the us records this
in a completely different way
and different processes different
structures
some are very good and have this in all
in an automated fashion
some are not there are some places um in
rural
texas where the literally the way that
people communicate polling places
is to just uh put a sign on the local
community notice board
saying yeah we're gonna do the uh
polling tomorrow and it'll be a bob's
house or something like that and it's
very very difficult to um to try to pull
this
together um and you know we need to go
from there to
um build a uh
to of come up with a comprehensive data
set of how we um
pull this together um but this is
completely indicative of most
public open data the vast majority of
public open data is
unstructured stale and unlicensed so
it's it's typically locked um
in a pdf somewhere typically not even in
a machine readable pdf but something
that's been scanned and converted into a
pdf
stale so typically when governments
produce
open data portals they take this data
and they um stick it up there
and then they forget about it so there's
no process to up
update this data and uh
and more often than not um unlicensed
and licensing is a really big deal
especially for people like um google you
know people
can and will sue us so it's very
important for us to be able to know that
we can
um use the data in the way it's intended
and if if
there isn't a license there for us to
use
um then there's very little we can do
um so to get ourselves out of this mess
what we did is we um
we founded a nonprofit called the voting
information project
and we funded that and this project they
started out by
trying to gather together as much of
this data
themselves by basically emailing
reaching out to the elections officials
in every
um state city and precinct across the
u.s collating that together into
a big list and then going through and
manually correcting it by hand
a lot of the initial work was um
done by googlers themselves we had a
tool up internal inside of google where
people could themselves fix up their own
data in their areas that they cared
about
and we did a big push um for this
um up to the uh 2008 elections
uh and we also defined a standard like
this we defined an xml standard the
machine readable standard
so that this voting information project
could act as
a hub basically the one true source that
aggregates together
and removes a lot of the problems that
we saw with this data so it ends up in a
format that is structured
that is uh has uh refreshed reliable
intervals
um and is um um
uh licensed uh and this is funded not
only by
um volunteers but also um google and now
a number of other
foundations um give money to this um
nonprofit to keep this government data
up to date
um and uh we aggregate that data
together we pull it into
google and that lets us build these
technologies on top of it which
for example tell you that you can vote
tomorrow and you can vote at this
particular
location we also republish this
data through apis to let other people um
build on top of it my favorite example
is that
this was the facebook stream
during the us midterms the last set last
year
saying i'm voting more information and
that's us facebook are linking out to
a project that we helped start so
occasionally you get some collaboration
in the tech industry
um uh but i use this as a nice
illustrious example of the kinds of
difficulties that you have to go to if
you want to attempt
to build anything using data that is
apparently
open so even when data is open
it is often
moving that into a um
a form that's actually usable is an
incredible uh amount of work much more
so than any of the computation owner
analysis or anything that you put
on top of it even down to the extent of
having to form particular structures
um with um uh nonprofits and things to
maintain this data
um we have actually done a very similar
thing once before back when i worked on
maps
to get google transit to work um so
transit data
uh this is a just an example of that
product as it stands today showing that
it is actually possible to get from our
office in san francisco to stanford
through public transport if you don't
mind spending an hour and 40 minutes on
caltrain
um uh but this is all possible for a
standard that we released
um called gtfs so the
we decided that this was back when i was
working in
europe the engineers there decided that
public transport is actually incredibly
important outside the u.s so as we were
launching
maps outside the u.s we decided it was
time to put public transport into
google maps and we naively went to all
of the top-tier
cities like london and paris and that
kind of thing and said hey could you
please just give us all your transit
data
and they they basically said no
initially
um and then after lots of um
um negotiations with them they would say
well
okay but you have to display it in
exactly the way that we display it on
our site no changes
and we won't give you the data you will
have to call out to our services
and and pull that data in which is just
totally impractical for
for building a project like um google
maps
um so then we played the other approach
and we went to the second tier cities
and we went to um places like in the uk
manchester kind of up-and-coming
cities and said hey do you want to
out-innovate london if you want to
out-innovate london you want to kind of
um show that you're uh that you're
really an up-and-coming city
would you partner with us and and share
your transit data with us
and so we um we started talking to these
cities and we drafted
a specification called
at the time it was called the google
transit feed specification gtfs
since now the general feed transit feed
specification
and we got a couple of initial partners
i can't even remember who the first
panel was i think it was german somebody
in germany munich maybe
we got them to start sharing data with
us in this open standard and at the same
time they would publish that open
standard on their own websites
too and gradually gradually gradually
over the course of about five or six
years
we were able to to pick off the
um other cities too um and move up to
the kind of the
uh secondary cities and lots of
different countries and then eventually
get to the point where
we could go back to people like paris
london and new york and say
you know you're looking pretty
embarrassing now because i can search
for public transit everywhere except
your city
isn't this a bit um silly and eventually
they relented and they started
publishing data in
in these formats too um and i think the
lesson there is that the
uh uh you know it is actually possible
both in terms of voter information
projects
uh and gtfs to go from a world where you
have
very very stale unlicensed
difficult to use data and eventually
gradually move
people to a world where the
the data is machine readable and
available for everybody to use
and i think actually that you know more
important than
um the uh transit directions in google
maps has been an explosion in
recent years of very very specific
transit uh applications especially on
your phone like if anybody uses
citymapper i'm a huge fan of
citymapper which is an alternate transit
application and they're only possible
because this data is now openly
available so this work helped kickstart
a whole ecosystem of these products
which is exactly the kind of thing that
we want to do
so it took a long time to build
consensus and i think one of the
key um lessons here is that the the
driving force of this was actually being
able to build
a product that people loved and cared
about it was much
easier for us to when we went into these
negotiations to say
you know we have x hundred million
people using maps and they would really
love to
use uh transit directions you know can
you help us and and
we were able to work together because
there was a clear user benefit either in
maps or
for election information uh and i think
as part of the challenge of the rest of
the open data
ecosystem because we managed to drag or
help drag
um the the data standards for these two
domains forward because we had a
compelling product
and um i think hopefully all of you
share my belief that the there's huge
potential for using these open data
sources to be
um a massively uh positive vector for
change in society
um uh and build great products on top of
it but we're not there yet we're at this
kind of
we're teetering on the the brink of this
hype cycle where
lots of um government agencies cities
have spent an awful lot of money and
time and effort
putting up open data portals sharing all
of this data
unlicensed stale pdfs um in the name of
transparency really
and then waiting for all the benefit to
come and in a lot of cases there has
been no benefit so far
and in fact if the only benefit has
really been in a few cases this is my
favorite example from the uk
where they put the
expense reports up for all of the
members of parliament
and you know even though that data was
stale and not machine readable because
it's so juicy and salacious
lots of investigative journalists are
very very keen to run through that data
and find for example one of the
conservative mps who
filed an expense uh report for
maintaining a moat for his ducks in his
back garden of his second home and you
can imagine what the public thought
about that
um but i use this as an illustrator
example is if if
the path forward to
moving to a true world of open data
where data is open and useful
involves dragging it forward with
world-changing
easy-to-use public services that make a
real difference things like this
like this is you know this is the kind
of thing that is happening with the data
at the moment and there's a whole
of the positive things that people are
using to analyze this data
um so i hope uh that's some
encouragement for everybody in this room
who deals with this data to go and think
like how can i make use of this data and
how i can actually turn this
this point we are in this hype cycle of
of taking the momentum around exposing
this data that exists now and turning it
into something that's actually
useful and and being able to do
something like we did with voter
information project or gtfs with all the
other public data that's being
made available
so that's one thing i will
there's a few challenges to opening data
one is is making it
stale um making sure it's not stale and
making sure it's licensed and machine
readable
um this is a from the open knowledge
foundation
census you can check this basically
ranks um cities in the u.s
as to on these characters it says is
your data
does your data match these criteria so
you can go and search for open knowledge
foundation census and
and i use new york as an example at the
top because
uh new york is probably one of the most
forward-looking cities
um in the world for using open data and
it's
uh you know the fact that michael
bloomberg was there as mayor is clearly
an impact on it they have
a large and incredibly respected team
um working behind this kind of thing
which is why they're at the top of the
rankings and a lot of their data is
green
so they're a huge success story in this
space
but just to illustrate some of the other
challenges
oh it's uh this is like a wiki type page
so if you think that the
city has data that meets those
requirements you can say
i will add it to this this list i don't
know
exactly yeah yeah so that means i don't
know yeah yeah
um so there are definitely other
challenges to working with this data so
i'll give one
illustrative example from new york and
you know like i say new york are doing
an amazing job at this case
but even when you have an amazing team
on it this is the challenges of the
space we're dealing with
so this story starts with um the new
york data people publishing this
fantastic graph of taxi facts
so i don't know there's anybody who've
spent time in new york
presumably some people spend time in
york you may have noticed
um that between the hours of four and
six pm in the evening it is impossible
to find a taxi
and it's impossible to find a taxi
because you drive a taxi in new york you
need a taxi medallion and taxi
medallions are hugely expensive
and so you don't have one per person you
share them between people
um and so when a driver goes off shift
they drive the car out of the city
because the the taxi firms typically
based out of manhattan and um
um they are uh the drivers live outside
of manhattan so they drive out of
manhattan
um they change the person over so that
they can take over the medallion and
they drive back into the center and
every taxi firm does this at the same
time
which seems kind of insane but that's
what happens so that graph you see there
um the black line is the number of taxis
on the road and the blue line is the
occupancy rate of the taxis so you can
see um
between uh four to six pm actually
there's 33 percent fewer taxes on the
road because everybody's going out
and um uh changing over millennials and
you know um parts of the reason why um
uh new york city releasing data like
this is to help sway
public affinity to like seed in people's
minds like this is a problem we have
data behind it you can go ahead and
analyze it
um this was a brief digression though
because it's not really the the point of
the story that i was
um making um a
uh civic hacker in the in new york
called chris wong
saw this graph and thoughts oh yes um
many of you may have heard the story
already i can see some people laughing
because you know what happens next
um said this looks like delicious data i
would like to use this
and do some interesting um analysis on
it so
he filed a freedom of information
request to new york city and said please
could you give me all of the data that
you used to make this graph because i
would like to run some analysis on it uh
and you know many freedom of information
requests get bogged down forever and
it's a fantastic the similar law in the
uk actually you can
basically any government run data you
can just request i would like this data
and they have to respond
um they can you know uh they may not
respond promptly
um they may uh you have to cover their
costs too so it might be prohibitively
expensive in some cases but they have to
give you the data if it's if it's
um a publicly run organization so he
just thought he'd chance it he sent a
mail in and said uh
please connect this data and they
emailed back and said yes of course
you can have this data if you nip around
to our office with a blank hard drive
um we'll just give you all the data so
uh so that's what he did this afternoon
he he went to the
new york taxi commission and they gave
him i think something like
uh i can't remember how much but it's
only 200 gig
of um 200 gigs of individual taxi trips
in new york and the taxi trips look
something like this
it was of csv files
one line of a csv file per trip
and it had the start time end time of
the trip the lat long
of the pickup and the drop off the
amount of fare paid and the tip paid
um and then you have these
big string identifiers here so i should
say that chris wong who filed this data
you then went on to make some fantastic
visualizations of this data about
how taxis move across the city but he
left it at that but
once the data has been released by
freedom of information request it's
effectively licensed in the public
domain so he just
re-hosted this data thereby making it
available to a lot of
other researchers um another group
i can't remember which group it was um
took a look at this data and thought hmm
these large random strings here they
look very much like
md5 sums i wonder what their md5 sums
out
because they're clearly supposed to be
some anonymized unique identifier for
that particular taxi
and turns out that they are md5 sums of
the license plate for that taxi
uh and the license plate for the taxis
as you might expect is a very small set
there aren't that many license plates of
taxis
and so it's pretty easy to do a reversal
where you take all the license plates
uh that you can enumerate in new york
generate the md5 sums and reverse it to
basically de-anonymize and get back the
license plate
of the taxi journeys
and so that's exactly what another
research group did
uh and so immediately a second data set
was hosted uh
it wasn't immediate it was about three
months later i think where now instead
of a csv file of
start time pickup um and lat long
price and anonymize the identifier it
also had the license plate of the taxi
kind of okay so far because you know
license plate taxi still
doesn't necessarily tell you that much
because you know it's
it's you know you could consider it
relatively anonymous and whether or not
you actually have the license number
or some unique identifier that taxi
doesn't help
uh that much until another research
group started thinking
where can i find images of taxis
at a precise time and they thought well
i can find images for texas at precise
time in all of the celebrity spotting
magazines
so they went through all the celebrity
spotting magazines
found pictures of taxis with stars going
into the taxi
and then tied that back against the data
from the new york taxi company
and so now we can see that the courtney
kardashian
tipped 3.40 on a 16.50 fare
and indeed you know went from this place
to this place
which is of course as i'm sure you all
agree
a massive violation of any um definition
of privacy
and um uh
and i mentioned this mainly because um
not at all to say that new york
um did something um
crazy but um new york are probably the
leading institution in this space like
new york city is
some of the thought leaders in this
space and they find it really really
difficult to deal with these things
um and in the academic world as i'm sure
many of you know
privacy theory has um advanced a lot in
recent years and you know there are
many hot topics and you know many people
view differential privacy as
being you know the current gold standard
of what you can try to achieve and there
are plenty of techniques you can use to
anonymize this data
um but the reality is these techniques
are really really difficult to apply
uh you know i mean i've spent a bunch of
my own personal time
um researching this space and me as a
trained computer scientist
it takes me um you know weeks to fully
understand a particular technique and
work out how to to
implement it because the the the tools
aren't there to do this in the mass
market on the other side
you have people like new york who
literally now like they had no choice
they had to give away this data because
it was
requested for freedom of information so
there's this really really strong
desire to release data at the moment a
belief that it will help society but
it's clearly being hampered
because we don't have the tools
available to
people who are actually at the coalface
trying to deal with and anonymize this
data
question yes so how do they find photos
like this i mean it sounds like a hard
problem itself finding
photos with taxicabs where you can read
the license plate and you have movie
stars
uh i think i think if you wanted to go
the other way if you wanted to
for a particular record find out who it
was that would be tricky
but for this demonstration they just
went in the other direction they found
a picture of anybody any celebrity in
one of these magazines getting into a
car where you can see the license plate
and then once you go that way you can
work out like that yeah well i mean
i don't spend much time reading these
magazines but i'm led to believe
that it is a um there's a large amount
of um work there so
there's the gap between where
concepts like differential privacy are
in academia and actually having them
implied in practice where it's really
necessary is
is you know real and ends up with things
like this and this may well
you know situations like this may well
just lock up this flow of data for
public good you know potentially forever
so let me talk about a slightly
different strategy
um and this is google flu trends
and this is a case where um there are
two ways kind of approaching the data
problem
um one is dealing with this very messy
and complicated space of
open data and i talked about some of the
ways we approach this you know
the other is let's say you have a signal
that's already there
a signal that um exists that you would
like
to use but it is messy it is slow it is
expensive to get hold of
can we produce that same signal now cast
that same signal
using techniques that make it much
cheaper and easily repeatable
and that's exactly what flu trends um
seeks to do the
centers for disease control um have a
ground truth source
of uh influenza like illnesses and
that's basically correlated from
people who end up talking to doctors in
hospital in a diagnosis of having the
flu
so that's a grandchild source for the
flu it is
uh it obviously lags real life because
it takes a long time to
um collect and it takes a long time for
people to show up to hospitals
um and it is uh only available
at relatively large geographic areas you
can't kind of zoom in
particular areas and the us and the uk
and other places are fortunate to have
that signal there are plenty of other
places in the world that don't have
infrastructure to monitor that signal
so what google fully translates to do is
predict that signal
and so we partner with
centers for disease control um across
uh the world both here in the u.s and in
other countries and specifically the
reason why we do that is because
um it's a different signal to them you
know in any kind of surveillance system
it's for disease it's important to have
a mix of different signals because
it makes your system much more robust so
they use it as a
as a check against the data that they
collect from hospitals
but more importantly to us you can
compute it uh more quickly you can
cheaply and hopefully longer term
although we're still working on this
it's because it's somewhat experimental
compute it for much finer geographic
areas so you can start saying
um you know san francisco flu season is
spiking now but los angeles
isn't and a lot of different research
groups use that
signal as well in their ongoing research
so that's basically what it looks like
the uh
red line there is um what we predict
um the flu season is um the
green line is the actual data from
um the center for disease control
and i'll tell you a bit about how we
build the model in a second um this is
not the advanced science but the other
science bit is later on this is still
pretty easy stuff um
uh a couple of things to note that
you'll see actually just a casual
observation it's actually pretty good
it's pretty good there are two cases
where it it varies a bit
one bit is here we'll come back to this
later on um this is when there was the
media for around h1n1 if you remember
that bird flu
so what is the vertical axis sorry the
vertical axi
is volume of flu cases at a national
level
uh and the horizontal axis is time and
so the
uh the green line is the um uh
the cdc signal of effectively a metric
based on the number of people who show
up to hospitals
with influenza like illnesses and the
red one is our prediction
you'll notice another anomaly at the end
is where it spikes here
last year we over predicted the peak
of the the peak volume of the flu season
by about
a factor of two um leading many people
to write articles saying this is the end
of big data big data is dead
it's you know i kind of think so i i
will which is because back when flu
trends launched the articles are wow
this is amazing this is the flu trends
is often held up as the poster child of
big data analysis and and so when it
goes wrong
um yeah the reaction is the opposite way
so i'll tell you a bit more about
you know how and why that that happened
um
uh yeah
i should probably mention that one of
the reasons why we choose flu is that if
you look at the global
burden of disease influenza like
illnesses kill an awful lot of people
um awful lot of people get it awful lot
of people die from them because they're
old and firm
and they place a huge strain on
hospitals and things so
whatever the health services can do to
better predict or know about these
things in advance
that lets them respond much more
efficiently than they would
otherwise so how there you have the two
signals
in sync so you're not predicting in
advance or
no we are not predicting in advance we
could probably predict in advance
um separate problem what's valuable here
is now casting we are telling you
the value it is right now but we are
telling you it's
um much more in a much more timely way
than any other
service can give you um and a
for different geographic areas for much
finer grained areas
so this is roughly how it works what we
do is we
um we troll all the queries that people
um enter into google and we look for
queries that are correlated
with the ili signal so it's
probably worth mentioning the subtle
difference is we are not trying to
predict or now cast the number of people
with the flu
we are trying to predict our now cast
the signal that the cdc gives us
which maybe that's the number of people
out of the flu maybe it's not it's the
number of people who show up in hospital
that it's that's our ground truth
information
um and so you end up with um
when you do that and you we we rank all
that we look through all the queries we
rank them by correlation coefficient of
um um uh
how closely are they are correlated with
the
um uh cdc's data and so typically what
you end up with the correlated queries
look um a lot of to do with
uh people searching for remedies if they
have the flu you'd expect that
a lot of to do people just searching for
flu symptoms um
and then you have some things like high
school basketball which is correlated
because the high school basketball
season tends to be at the same time as
flu season and so
you know that just happens to be picked
up
and then so what we do again this is not
the advanced science part i will
i will warn you when the advanced
science part comes because i still think
this is very very basic you will be
surprised how basic this is
we simply sum up the most correlated
queries and
we build a logistic regression model
um for against the cdc's data
and we do that using eight seasons of
data uh
eight flu seasons and then we hold back
two seasons of that data as 20
of our input and we use that to evaluate
and then so we calculate um rms error at
peak
between um the um
cdc's data uh and our data so you
wouldn't believe how simple it is
uh and the queries we use we
um this is uh it's nice this should be
in like textbooks and things because as
you'd expect
if you add in queries you start with one
query and it's not actually that
correlated then you hit a sweet spot in
the middle and the sweet spot ends up to
be about
50 queries and then as you add in more
and more queries to the model you start
overfitting and it doesn't work anymore
and so you know you get the the nice
kind of
bell shape you would expect of um of
when you plot rms error against number
of queries in the model so the model
only looks at
roughly 50 queries and those 50 queries
are um uh
pulled automatically based on the first
pulled automatically by
how much they're correlated with the
signal and then pruned out manually to
reduce the ones that
are um clearly not correlated like high
school basketball if that indeed
um showed up um
so let's go as this works really well
um over prediction at the um
um uh last year
so you said i said well you know why did
over predict
let's debug this let's work it out we
should say that typically
um we retrain this model
um well now we retrain it more
frequently at the time we retrained it
very infrequently
we retrained it we trained it once in
2008 and then we retrained it
after h1n1 because there was enough
media attention that that started
skewing the signal
and then we didn't retrain it again so
the same model was working without
change for for so long
so reasons it might not work you know
model might be robust
um maybe it was an effect of us
retraining after h1n1 for some reason
maybe the query stream we
we trained on after h1n1 was different
from before
maybe it was sensitive to media
retention in the news
maybe people's search behavior changed
uh
perhaps actually and this was actually
like a lot of researchers in the
community who work in this space
uh you know epidemiologists said
actually maybe what you're monitoring
here is you're trying to fit against
the um the ili data from hospitals
but that's not the number of people have
the flu maybe what your model is
actually doing is telling you
who has the flu and that explains why
there is this gap and maybe it's
something that didn't get picked up
otherwise
um and maybe actually the the search
queries aren't causal enough and it's
not possible to pull this thing together
um give you a spoiler for later on there
is no single reason why
it doesn't work properly uh so first of
all let's look at the query fraction
that is the same graph you saw earlier
but that's the volume of queries that
each color is a different query that we
put into the model there if we expand it
out to look at the fraction
um this is uh what happened um
uh over time and you'll see if we zoom
in to around the time when we over
predicted
that big green thing there um
yeah so the each of those different
colored bars is a different
query in the model and you're looking at
volume as a fraction of the query stream
and the green one at the bottom is flu
symptoms so that is a query that was
spiking that's the main culprit in terms
of providing data into our model
um so it was in the 2008 model um
but then we took it out after 2008 just
because
things started getting picked up in the
press made it back in in the automated
model in 2009 not there in 2013.
um it wasn't the only query that spiked
in the model there are plenty of others
that are spiking there you see some at
the top that are decorative tolerated
and spiking but it was the one that
spiked
the most um so we can't attribute
the entire course to that it's not
solely responsible
to that but it's it's definitely you
know the model is sensitive to that
particular query because there's only
50 queries in the model um
so the um the second question is was
there something different about the h1n1
season when we trained on the query
stream um after h1n1
um was there something weird about that
so we
we retrained the model and we took out
that season of
data um and then we
because h191 you remember was in the
news a lot of media retention you'd
expect it to
perhaps do something so we retrained um
without that
it did give some slight improvement not
a massive improvement definitely
improved
and then a hand analysis of the type of
queries that made it into the model
we kind of you know look through by hand
bucket them into what these queries mean
what information is the user seeking
um uh the uh updated model without that
season was much more about the
the um symptoms people searching for
specific symptoms whereas the other one
was um people searching for um
particular um remedies and particular
medicine so there was
the two different models definitely
picked up a different set of queries
but it's um the difference there was not
significant enough to really be yeah
fundamental
one question is it possible that
heightened media attention made it the
case because you know we are since we
measured user queries maybe people were
more aware maybe they thought this flu
season was
um to uh was worse
uh and at the time there was a lot of
news articles written about
um um flu in 2013 when our model
overpredicted
so we thought it's uh perhaps there is
um
perhaps there's something there in the
you know perhaps the news actually took
hold of people and people are searching
more frequently
very difficult for us to work out how to
verify that
hypothesis we thought couldn't think of
much
um what we um did
is we did something very simple but we
just did google news
and we searched google news for flu and
built a signal out of that
and that basically gave us a um
a summary of the volume of news about
flu
for that um um season and then we used
that signal
to prorate the number of queries that we
use to effectively correct
um for the news volume um to see whether
or not that helped to basically weigh
down the fact that if the qu
if the um flu season was more um
uh reported in the media that time uh
turned out didn't really
help that much a little bit another
interesting thing in terms of the google
system
um during that time the use of suggest
on google
keeps growing and growing growing people
love suggest um
suggest has a very interesting property
of massively compressing the query
stream
as you might expect because people
accept suggestions rather than typing
something in and so you see the
diversity of queries reduced down
perhaps what was happening was that that
was reducing the
query stream um down to the point where
the the user was typing in a query that
would have been
picked up by the model but then diverted
by suggest to a query that wasn't in the
model or vice versa
perhaps that was the case um
so we did an analysis of uh basically
how many
queries um into um
flu trends um uh came from suggest
uh and lots of them though like that
number is increasing you can see
uh the graph basically shows what
fraction of the um
queries end up in that uh model that
come into google via suggest and
end up in the model um that definitely
changed over the years definitely um
is definitely a factor to um um
to uh take into account um
but the uh
the that increasing ratio doesn't appear
correlated with the change
so after we analyzed to see whether or
not that's the
uh the query diversion rate from suggest
was correlated with our error it wasn't
so it's not like that uh and lastly you
know
there is something like was it a
phenomena like was it just something
where we were picking up
some perhaps perhaps the flu season was
slightly less um virulent than than
usual so maybe it was
maybe what was happening is that people
got the flu but then it wasn't serious
enough to go to hospital then we would
see
a flu season symptom for example and our
signal would go up
but then the ili signal from hospitals
wouldn't go up because people didn't
turn up
um so we cross correlated with both
flew near you which is a research
project that we
help fund where they basically do
self-reported diagnosis they ask people
whether or not they have the flu
and lab tests from the cdc and neither
of those showed anything different
from previous so we don't it doesn't
look very likely it's not conclusively
that this wasn't the case but it seems
unlikely
so summary like um
you know what was here was the model not
robust like it was definitely a factor
the flu trends query spike the flu
simpsons query spiked
and um uh not enough to fully cause that
change but it was one
one of the answers um
was it an update for the h1n1 update
kind of it wasn't related to h1n1 we we
retrained the model and just happened to
pull in queries that are more use
sensitive
um was it kind of sensitive to media
attention it was
yes it was sensitive to media attention
but it depends on what queries end up in
the model so
the technique isn't necessarily
dependent on
on it just that particular model was it
doesn't look like it was caused
in in such behavior
haven't ruled out that it's not a uh
a phenomena that we uh that we detected
and other people didn't
but we don't think it's likely
uh and lastly is it because you just
can't draw causation
from search queries um i'll leave that
to as an exercise
to you in the audience um
so what we're working on now uh this is
the advanced science bit
this one sentence is the most advanced
thing i say we have since improved the
model
um we don't just use simple logistic
regression at the moment what we have is
a
an autoregressive component that
predicts based on the previous
seasons just on the previous season's
data in combination with
um an elastic net on the same query um
selection mechanism which uh gives us
makes the model considerably more robust
to the single query changes that we saw
earlier um we're
collaborating with external partners to
actually try to find ways that we can
make sure this data is used um in
practice
and finding ways to be more transparent
with the data community like yourselves
um about what we're working on um
and that's uh i felt i should leave the
talk on a high note because i
i spent the first half of the talk
saying how bad government technology and
data typically is um so i'll highlight a
very good piece of government technology
um this is the um a blog by the gds team
so i think if i was ranking
countries in the world with their
technical capacity in the
government estonia would probably be
number one the uk would be number two
partly because they have an in-house
team of software engineers who are very
very good
um and one of the things they've started
doing is using the same techniques such
as about flu trends but
on their own service so in the uk the
this
gds teaming government have um spent a
long time redesigning a lot of online
google services and winning lots of
design awards to the extent where they
have
one portal gov.uk where you can do
everything from
apply for a passport to renew a driving
license that kind of thing
and that has given them the position of
a large stream of traffic to work with
and so they are doing things like
um building auto-aggressive models
on top of the number of applications
that they see online
to detect anomalies so if the number of
passport applications is increasing
faster than their model predicts then
maybe that means there is uh something
going on in the outside world and they
should actually investigate that because
otherwise the passport application
processing system will
collapse so i leave it as a final
thought
that actually there is
plenty of examples in government of
people doing amazing things with
technology and with that i hope that
i've a
inspired you to go and look at societal
data and use
data science to use that ugly word to
help
improve things and you need to ask any
questions that people have
yes uh you have a plot where you show
the proportion
of the total searches for each type of
um
creature term and so don't the green the
big green one with the
blue seasons yes and then the one right
above it was the orange one and it
seemed
almost correlated to the sum of green
plus orange was nearly constant
that was uh i don't know i'd have to go
back and look at the data but yes i mean
um quite possible that graph is for
illustration what we
um basically did when we investigate
this is take queries out one at a time
and see which one had the biggest effect
because it's always difficult when you
sum all these things together i mean the
whole reason why you sum all the crews
together in the first place is to get
this robustness factor um
but yes that's the okay so that that
particular
that particular case is why that that
one query spiking
um is not a true but it doesn't cover
the whole error because that one query
is spiking and other queries going to
reduce because people are just
accepting different you know entering
different things
yeah thank you for this interesting talk
um
so i'm very curious about this flu
trends method that you
discussed in terms of have you tried to
check
other signals using the same method and
see you know with other
signals is it also going to be every
decade or so it's going to
be off or is this something just happens
for this particular
signal so like trying to empirically
test how robust this method is
i see what i mean um do we uh
trying to find other different signals
we could use in the model or
or just predict them through um search
search volume using this similar method
and just
check you know for those other
predictions do they also have the same
kind
of find other signals yeah um we have i
mean
to the extent it's kind of that approach
is built in and the way that we
when we pick the the top most correlated
queries we
we do that looking at eight years of
data and so we rank all of those
um things so that we use as much data as
we can when we pick it
it's possible that what we could do is
play with the time frames so maybe we
sample different queries at different
times maybe we mix them together
that kind of thing um definitely not
something that we're working on um right
now we're kind of looking at more
how do you make the existing query
selection more robust in the presence of
individual
spikes um sorry i didn't make my
question clear still
um so instead of flu yes what if we had
a different disease
disease another different disease so
this general method ah have we applied
the general method to other things
yes yes we have so we we also do for
dengue fever
and we do a lot of the work uh dengue
fever is one of the
worst diseases in the developing world
and the developing world is
a particular note because the while
while what we do in the us
is uh basically now cast the signal that
the cdc have
for things like dengue there is there is
no cdc and there is no
um a surveillance system in many of
these countries and so
the goal is that we train on queries in
one country and one language that does
have ground truth data and then be able
to apply that exact same signal
to countries that don't have it and so
that's where we work with cdc's in these
companies
in these countries to supply it and in
those cases i mean it's clearly noisier
because you're taking a model that was
trained in one case and applying it to
another
um but uh equally there's nothing else
so you know it's better than nothing so
yes to that extent we do
uh we have tried it with other things
our main focus right now is
rather than expanding the the coverage
of the different things we could model
um it is uh
proving like the whole concrete system
of how you take this data
and make a positive change in the real
world with this because it's pretty easy
like
you could give me any signal and i could
model it for you we could just run the
same pipeline and we could model it
that's not really interesting to me
what's interesting to me the system
effects of how you actually affect this
change in the real world
same reason why the data side is if
google
encourages people to evolve does that
lead to imbalance because
the population that
uses google it's not the same as
it is a very it's a very good ethical
process
it's a very good question um definitely
one that we wrangle with as a team
internally
i mean at the moment the principle is
that lots of different companies
facebook everybody encourage you to vote
it's just accepted that it's i mean to
some extent it's like social
um uh social acceptance and at the
moment
the decided thing is that it's perfectly
reasonable and people should be doing
this but i
completely agree that you could argue
that
yeah what what does coal phase mean
oh coffee oh sorry it's a yeah
it's the rather it's the rather quaint
british expression
uh it means uh the uh uh it's the
opposite it's a cutting edge
it's actually the the people doing like
doing the real work in the trenches and
down the coal mine
mining in the mines giving the calls yes
being british i do try to put as many
british expressions into my talks as
possible
to confuse people yeah
so what does this see what does the cdc
do that actually like helps people
like you know you build this this model
and found a signal and you can predict
things faster and then
you can measure them but how does that
actually help people well so one
concrete thing that hospitals can do the
cdc
do this disease surveillance they can
tell um
the city of well the state of california
you are going to have flu season
in three weeks according to our models
or flu season is occurring like you can
see the uptake coming up now
so um you are going to expect a massive
influx of people into hospitals so you
should go
and basically temporarily increase your
capacity by
hiring agency workers agency nurses
moving non-critical patients out of beds
that kind of thing it basically helps
with general hospital and patient
optimization because it's if you wait
until the last minute and people are
backing up in the
corridors of your hospital clearly it's
much much much less efficient
medications stock medications decide
when the right point to do vaccinations
and things is that's the um
yeah does what would you say would be
the overall theory of change or theory
of
impact that drives the work of google
for social impact
uh that's a complicated question it's
a uh difficult google i mean it's it's a
union of a number of things
one is are we building things that help
more than just google users
um do we believe um
it has a positive impact in the world by
some definable metric
and is there a team of people at google
who are passionate enough
to work on it so it's a trifecta um
of all of those things i don't know if
that's concrete enough for you but
that's how it works in practice
i mean i can give you a um one concrete
thing is
um i work in crisis response
we uh we buzz your phones uh if we think
your life is in him in danger but we
also act as a convener
of information during a crisis and we
have this crisis map product that lets
people produce ugc data to have the
facts on the ground during a crisis
we have more effort on the former than
the latter and that's because
our goal is to save lives and the most
effective way of saving people's lives
in crises
is to get them out of the way of the
crisis in the first place than it is to
try and mop up
afterwards so we um we bias
that towards the other but in every case
it's it's like what is the objective
metric
of real world impact we're trying to
affect
and are we going to be able to do that
kind of spoke a little bit about the
tension sometimes that happens between
accessing big data for the benefit of
society and also on protecting privacy
and individuals
and so i guess like in the information
you gathered for this project or any
projects that are similar to it were
there any um or what were the challenges
that you
faced and um privacy issues
um i mean the challenges in the to be
honest the projects that i
um talked about in terms of privacy
there
for flu trends because you're dealing
with such um
large query volumes and because you are
it's almost impossible for an individual
user
to have a particular effect um and you
can do the
you know you can do some trivial uh
analysis and do the work to prove
differential privacy and things like
that and given this particular case
um but um
because we're operating at such a high
level it's not a problem you know if we
were
to for example go to down to an
individual street level and try to
predict flue in your street
clearly the privacy implications there
are much much more complicated and we
would have to a
decide whether it was worth the
trade-off there and b
um probably do the academic work to
prove that it's differentially private
and
those kind of things um so the
particular things i mentioned there
um don't have a
large impact but to most of these
projects of people working in the open
data space
you definitely have to be conscious of
these things which is why i think that
um actually finding a way to bridge this
chasm at the moment between academic
privacy research
and what people apply in practice in the
field is increasingly important
no more questions oh one more last one
you mentioned that you guys would have
to make a decision about whether it's
worth
whether that trade-off is worth it is
there any kind of any other kind of
oversight or is it really just up to you
guys whether you want to do it
um yeah
difficult question i mean at the moment
we uh
we've not been in a space where i think
we've ever come across
questions like that where um it
is uh you know of um
enough impact to the world that we would
we would want to vet that i mean clearly
there are well-established frameworks in
the academic community through irbs and
that kind of thing to
um to do that and that's definitely a
technique that we would probably look
into in those kind of cases
so far we've not been in a position
where we've needed to
do that let's thank the speaker again
you